[Musique]
tout va bien chéri
moi je suis entrepreneur et mon domaine
de prédilection c'est les gouttes tu
sais qu'il faut que je sois au courant
de tout dans ces rues
la bagnole est là
[Applaudissements]
il marche plus ou quoi
[Musique]
écoutez je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
mais c'était pas moi
[Musique]
même là dedans
c'est notre chez nous si on fait rien
personne ne sortira de cette merde
tranquille tranquille tu te calmes
[Applaudissements]
ok il est mort il faut rester positif va
chercher les serviettes humides on va le
faire revenir
protégerait toujours ce que j'aime par
tous les moyens moi j'ai pas peur je
suis capable
monsieur pourriez-vous m'indiquer où se
trouve l'ascenseur qui mène au
laboratoire flippant
et je disparais de votre vie à jamais
c'est parti mec
nous sommes sur place pour savoir ce qui
s'est passé exactement alors là c'est le
groupe elles sont en train de cloner des
Noirs ces enclos des lois qu'est-ce qui
se passe c'est une théorie qui prévoit
vu les circonstances